le soir jean marc sylvestre merci d'être
avec nous ravie de vous retrouver en
direct sur rt france ce forum a maintenu
donc on le disait cette année quels en
sont les enjeux en pleine pandémie
eh bien vous savez ce forum de saint
pétersbourg est considéré dans le monde
entier comme le rival du forum de davos
qui se tient en général dans cette
station suisse et qui rassemble des
milliers de chefs d'entreprises ou de
dirigeants du monde entier d'avant ça a
été annulé deux fois de suite
la russie a voulu montrer qu'il fallait
cette année se remettre au travail et
considérer les nouvelles conditions
économiques de la préco vite parce que
saint pétersbourg et bien c'est un forum
de business qui rassemble un certain
nombre d'entreprises ont via un simple
hyper ce bourg pour discuter business
pour signer des contrats et pour faire
des affaires
les entreprises viennent ici du monde
entier elles viennent de tous les
continents d'asie d'afrique mais aussi
d'europe et même d'amérique en dépit des
difficultés qu'il a pu y avoir au niveau
des rapports entre le reste du monde et
la russie alors avec des conditions et
verra le disais il ya un instant tri
sont très particulières mais je suis
officiel de russie ont voulu montré
qu'ils étaient capables d'organiser un
forum de cette envergure dans toutes
conditions de sécurité en protégeant du
coc vie une façon peut-être de faire
taire un certain nombre de soupçons qui
circulait dans la communauté nationale
sur lequel la russie avait traité un peu
laxiste en matière de protection et puis
peut-être aussi en matière de
vaccination alors on le on le sait un
jean-marc on le constate tous les jours
le
russie bashing sur le plan géopolitique
est ce que c'est la même chose dans les
affaires où la communication tout d'un
coup on est beaucoup plus fluide quand
on parle business
écoutez rocha bachy et est évidemment
présent dans les esprits il est présent
dans les conversations et un peu dans
dans les attitudes ça vous a pas échappé
ce forum s'ouvre quelques jours après
cette affaire de l'avion de biélorussie
qui a quand même beaucoup refroidi
l'atmosphère internationale ce forum
existe aussi pour montrer de façon très
claire et très précis que d'un côté il
ya la politique avec ses rapports de
force avec ses désaccords avec parfois
ces conflits n'est que de l'autre il y a
des intérêts économiques et je crois que
tous ces participants ici qui sont chefs
d'entreprise banquiers ou parfois
autorités administratives et bien sont
d'accord pour relire avec l'idée qu'il
faut protéger les intérêts économiques
le développement parce que c'est un
facteur de progrès et que c'est un
facteur de paix c'est donc à cela qu'ils
vont ça qui fait qu n'empêche que sur le
terrain politique
on comptait discuter ça peut handicaper
ans parfois la signature les
conversations économique mais ça reste
de la politique les affaires économiques
sont des affaires beaucoup plus
pragmatique qui met en rapport des gens
qui ont envie de travailler ensemble et
on le rappelle un forum qui se tient
alors que la russie doit toujours
répondre composer avec un les sanctions
dont elle fait l'objet
alors c'est vrai que les sanctions
planent
la russie doit composer avec ces
sanctions mais ce qui inquiète plus
particulièrement les hommes d'affaires
ici ce sont les menaces les nouvelles
menaces de sanctions consécutives à la
sphère de l'avion le biélorusse
c'est vrai que d'un côté comme de
l'autre du côté occidental comme du côté
russe on craint mais sanction qui ce qui
reviendrait si vous voulez a bloqué une
partie notamment des transactions
financières qui sont utilisés dans le
monde aujourd'hui
alors tout le monde pense qu'il faudra
être très prudent là dessus tout le
monde pense que du côté occidental
eh bien ces sanctions sont de la
communication politique peut-être de
l'imposture notamment de la part de
l'europe qui les a proféré de façon
claire mais que les réponses du
président poutine sont aussi et tout le
monde l'a constaté relativement prenant
alors on le rappelle en pleine pandémie
se tient ce forum les vaccins bien
encore l'accès aux médicaments est ce
qu'ils sont au menu de ce forum alors
que l'agencé européenne du médicament
doit rendre son avis prochainement sur
les vaccins russe pique nique
alors absolument absolument vous avez
raison la russie a mis au programme la
question de la santé mondiale et a
programmé notamment un certain nombre de
discussions sur la diffusion au niveau
international des vaccins on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
coopération dans les échanges entre les
laboratoires sur la connaissance de la
maladie et sur la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de traitements mais on
s'est aussi aperçu des dégâts et alors
que les méthodes les diagnostics ont été
particulièrement semblables dans la
plupart des pays du monde on est tous
revenus plus ou moins à des méthodes de
confinement mais la coopération sur les
vaccins s'est avéré beaucoup plus
fragile dès lors qu'il y avait des
intérêts économiques dès lors qu'il y
avait des intérêts financiers
c'était la concurrence et puis aussi il
y avait peut-être des intérêts
politiques le vaccin russe le spoutnik
est un produit d'exportation un produit
d'exportation qui devient très important
pour la russie dans beaucoup de pays du
monde notamment l'a fait quand
l'amérique du sud et en asie sauf en
europe
vous le disiez parce que l'europe n'a
toujours pas donné son agrément à
l'utilisation du vaccin russe alors
virus sont très vigilants ils sont très
attentifs et sont très impatients sur
cette question parce qu'ils savent que
leur population est assez réticente
aujourd'hui elle a un problème de
confiance envers de la vaccination
et beaucoup d'observateurs se disent ici
que si l'europe venait à apporter son
agrément
oslo spoutnik et bien la population
russe ne se vaccinent ray de façon plus
volontiers et plus accéléré c'est une
question importante parce que on ne
sortira de cette pandémie que lorsque le
monde entier aura été vaccinées
l'occasion jean marc seiwert aussi de
s'interroger sur l'état de la
coopération économique franco russe
où en est elle
alors écoutez une taille la coopération
franco russe
elle est plus elle n'a pas souffert
énormément delà de la situation du pô
vide
elle n'a pas trop souffert non plus des
sanctions qui ont été mises en place
elles risqueraient de souffrir en
revanche si les menaces de sanctions qui
ont été proférées était exercée et
aboutissent et à l'exclusion de la
russie du système de financement
internationaux cette coopération franco
russe se traduit par un flux des
échanges importants notamment en gaz et
pétrole on achète beaucoup d'énergie à
la russie le groupe total par exemple
est sans doute allé premier client de la
russie sont d'ailleurs très présents ici
en russie mais pas seulement il ya des
changes du bois industriel on a un
certain nombre d'investissements qui
sont localisés l'intérêt de la russie
c'est quelque part de sortir un petit
peu du piège de la rente pétrolière
c'est à dire que la une des activités
principales
en termes de produit intérieur brut
c'est évidemment l'exploitation de son
gaz l'exploitation de son pétrole
la russie voudrait évidemment se
diversifier pour se diversifier il faut
attirer des investisseurs attirer des
implantations industrielles et c'est un
peu ce à quoi peut servir un forum comme
celui de de saint pétersbourg alors
l'europe l'europe de son côté plus envie
du et la france est un peu jamais allé
dire un peu coincé dans cette affaire
parce que l'europe est partagée par sa
fidélité historique aux états unis après
tout il ya le temps qui nous protège au
niveau militaire et la proximité
géographique culturelle de la russie
mais ça c'est un peu politique sur le
terrain économique les choses se passent
beaucoup mieux que sur le terrain
politique
merci beaucoup aux marques assignation
directe de saint-pétersbourg